first up it's breakfast and my
incredibly easy fragrant crispy filo
delicious with a simple honey yogurt now
these are beautiful filo pastry sheets
now it is possible to make it but to be
honest let's try and stretch the pastry
that thin and get it even it's an
absolute nightmare likes too short to
make it at home when you can buy amazing
feel at pastry so when working with it
always get a nice damp cloth and just
lay the damp cloth over it that keeps it
nice and moist
and it stops the filo pastry I'm
actually trying out a pan on to melt
your butter it's the butter that gives
the crisps penis to the filo pastry
if you ever gonna brush or coat filo
pastry with butter let make sure that
butter is nicely seasoned you take your
first layer layer onto the board nicely
brush that with your butter and the nice
thing about filo pastry is that it can
be used for savory and sweet these are
gonna have a fragrant savory flavor with
thyme black pepper and Parmesan cheese
so no need for salt lift up the corner
unfold very quickly brush the ends
and just nip those ends together
non-stick pan on little splash of olive
oil fry the pastry for one to two
minutes on each side so you want them to
sort of puff up the secrets cook them
quickly you can smell that cheese in
that time you're looking for them to
become golden and crispy simple as that
and then out smells delicious
and as they sit and cool down instantly
they become really nice and crispy the
fee that goes fantastically well with
fake creamy Greek yogurt and a drizzle
of runny honey there's something quite
sort of Middle Eastern about the herbs
of the yoga and the honey and the sort
of crispy textures of the Phaedo pastry
alternative savory breakfast when you
want a stunning and sophisticated
breakfast that mixes fragrant herbs and
cheese with glorious honey yogurt this
middle-eastern treat hits the spot and
it's so simple to make